When Nunzio first saw the bike, he knew. It was a little Honda motorcycle from 1966, with an engine so small that, officially, I think you're supposed to call it a scooter. It was in a neighbor's yard. He was 13.
当Nunzio第一次看到那辆摩托车时，他就认定了。那是一辆1966年的小本田摩托车，引擎非常小，我觉得正式叫法应该是轻便摩托车。它就在邻居的院子里。当时他13岁。
I absolutely remember it. Yeah, it was against the shed. Grass was growing all over it. It was red, but they had not taken care of it. And somebody put flat black paint all over the thing. Tires were flat. There was a couple of pieces missing from it.
我完全记得。是的，它靠在棚子边上。上面长满了杂草。车身是红色的，但他们根本没去保养。有人还在上面刷了平光黑漆。轮胎没气了。还缺了几个零件。
It's funny. So when you see it, it's kind of a wreck of a bike.
很有意思。所以当你看到它时，它就像是一堆废铁。
Yeah. It's a wreck of a bike with a dream of, I'm going to be the cool kid in the neighborhood with my friends and buddies.
没错。那是一堆废铁，但它承载着一个梦想，我想成为邻里间跟朋友们在一起时最酷的那个小孩。
His plan was he wanted to ride it around the railroad tracks with his buddies. They would hang out there or in the woods with their bicycles, get cigarettes from the older kids or a beer now and then. This was West Albany, New York, 1975. When Nunzio described this to me, the only thing I could picture was Stranger Things or the film Stand By Me. And then a friend of his brought that film up to describe what it was like.
他的计划是想和伙伴们骑着它在铁轨附近兜风。他们会和朋友们在铁轨旁或树林里晃悠，从大孩子那里讨根烟抽，或者偶尔喝瓶啤酒。那是1975年的纽约州西奥尔巴尼。当Nunzio向我描述这些时，我脑海中浮现的唯一画面就是《怪奇物语》或电影《伴我同行》。后来他的一位朋友也提到了这部电影，来形容那时的情形。
Anyway, so Nunzio pays this neighbor $50 cash with money he earned mowing lawns. Nunzio wasn't great at school, but even at 13, he had an unusual talent for fixing things and for engines. Like, he fixed his own lawn mower engine at that age. And he was excited to get the scooter home and to work on it in this workshop under his parents' porch. When he did, he discovered--
总之，Nunzio用他割草挣来的50美元现金买下了这辆邻居的车。Nunzio在学校表现并不好，但即使在13岁时，他在修理东西和引擎方面就有非凡的天赋。比如，他那个年纪就能修理自家的割草机引擎。他很兴奋地把轻便摩托车弄回家，在父母门廊下的车间里修理。当他开始动手时，他发现——
OK, so the engine was seized, come to find out. It was missing the overhead valve assembly.
好吧，结果发现引擎卡死了。顶置气门组件不见了。
Also, holes in the gas tank. Carburetor needed rebuilding. Battery was shot.
还有，油箱上有洞。化油器需要重修。电池也报废了。
So now, I kind of realize, I couldn't realistically cut enough lawns to get enough parts to get it running at that age.
所以现在，我意识到，在那个年纪，我不可能靠割足够的草来挣钱买齐零件让它发动起来。
OK, so you're 13. You realize this is going to be a big job. Do you just put it aside?
好吧，你才13岁。你意识到这将是一项艰巨的任务。你直接放弃了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
What happens?
后来发生了什么？
I set it aside. And it sat there for 24 years.
我把它搁置了。它在那里躺了24年。
During that near-quarter century, it laid in pieces all over the ground under this porch, he says. But he didn't forget it. He'd think about it now and then, always intended to get back to the scooter and do the rebuild that he couldn't afford as a kid. It ended up taking him on a much more circuitous route than he could have imagined.
在这将近四分之一个世纪里，它一直零件散落一地，躺在门廊下，他说。但他并没有忘记。他偶尔会想起它，总想着要回去修理这辆轻便摩托车，完成小时候因没钱而无法进行的修复。最终，这让他踏上了一条比他想象中曲折得多的道路。
Basically, what happened is that in 1999, Nunzio's parents sold the house, and he collected all the parts from under the porch and hauled them to where he now lived with his wife and his two young kids at the time, laid the stuff out in his garage, and finally got to work. He started searching for scooter parts. This was 1999, before everything was on the internet, so it took some doing.
基本上，事情是这样的：1999年，Nunzio的父母卖掉了房子，他把门廊下的所有零件收集起来，运到了他和妻子以及当时两个年幼的孩子住的地方，把东西铺在车库里，终于开始动手了。他开始搜寻轻便摩托车的零件。那是1999年，在万维网尚未普及的时代，这着实费了一番功夫。
Says he spent about a year piecing the thing together, finally got the engine barely running, realized he needed somebody to do a proper rebuild of the engine. Found a shop in Schenectady, put the engine in a cardboard box, dropped it off. The guy said, great, give me four or five weeks. I'll have it for you, good as new.
他说他花了一年左右的时间把车拼凑起来，终于让引擎勉强发动了，但他意识到自己需要专业人士来彻底重修引擎。他在斯克内克塔迪找了一家店，把引擎装进纸箱送了过去。那人说，没问题，给我四五周时间。我会把它修得和新的一样给你。
I called him, like, a month later. I'm getting to it. Things have been busy at the shop. Don't worry about it. I promise you we'll get to it. I call back in, like, two or three weeks. Hey, I got it all apart. I need the manual. And I said, OK. It took me a few weeks to get it. So another three weeks go by. And I deliver it up there. Said, here you go. Hey, when can I get it? Hey, it's going to take us a few weeks. We got it all apart. We're working on it. Looking great.
我一个月后打电话给他。他说，正在处理。店里太忙了。别担心。我保证会修好的。我又过了两三周打过去。嘿，我把它全拆开了。我需要手册。我说，好的。我花了几周才弄到。又过了三周。我把它送过去。说，给，在这儿。嘿，我什么时候能拿到车？嘿，还需要几周。我们都拆开了。正在弄。看起来很棒。
More months pass. Finally, six or seven months in, Nunzio says he calls the shop, and the phone is disconnected. He drives there. Seems to be permanently closed. Goes to the literal phone book. Remember? 1999. Calls people with the guy's last name, finds two relatives, he says, who say they haven't seen him. He knows he should just buy another engine, either a new engine or another old engine from the 1960s from the same model bike, but just can't bring himself to do it.
又过了几个月。最后，六七个月过去了，Nunzio说他给店里打电话，电话已注销。他开车过去。看起来是永久关闭了。他去查电话簿。记得吗？1999年。他给那个人的同姓人打电话，找到了两个亲戚，据他说，他们表示没见过那个人。他知道他本该买个新引擎，或者是同样型号车的旧引擎，但他就是下不了手。
None of those choices were acceptable to me. The most important thing here, I would say, for me, was keeping it all original, to have the exact bike when I took it at 13 still today.
那些选择我都不接受。我想说，对我而言最重要的事情是保持原装，让我今天拥有的车就是我13岁时拿到的那辆。
Why?
为什么？
Because it was really a piece of time of me with my friends at that age.
因为它记录了我那个年纪和朋友在一起的时光。
Years go by. He kind of gives up on this engineless, hopeless bike. Finally one Sunday night, the kids are in bed. He goes online and searches for the name of the guy he left the engine with and learns, no wonder he can't find him. The guy is locked up, convicted on an illegal dumping charge. Nunzio figures out where he's doing time and visits him the very next day.
岁月流逝。他几乎放弃了这辆没有引擎、毫无希望的破车。终于在一个周日晚上，孩子们睡了。他上网搜索了他留下引擎那个人的名字，才发现难怪他找不到人。那个人被关进监狱了，因为非法倾倒废弃物被判刑。Nunzio查到了他服刑的地方，第二天就去探视。
So they bring you in there. It's just like the movies. You're sitting at this table, and there's a piece of glass 10 inches between the two. You're not allowed to put your hands over the glass. And he comes out, and he sits at the table. And the first question he says to me is, do I know you? And I said, yes, I gave you my scooter engine years ago, and I want it back.
他们把你带进去。就像电影里演的一样。你坐在桌子旁，中间隔着10英寸的玻璃。你不允许把手伸到玻璃上方。他出来了，坐在桌子对面。他问我的第一个问题是，我认识你吗？我说，是的，几年前我把轻便摩托车引擎给你了，我要拿回来。
OK, probably not the answer the guy was expecting.
好吧，这可能不是那个人预想的回答。
And he said to me, you tracked me down to prison for a scooter engine? I said, yes. I had it since 13, and it's important to me. I want to get it running. He goes, yeah, I have it. And he was extremely helpful, really nice. And he gave me the address. And he said to me, you tell him I sent you there. You tell him you visited me in jail. And you tell him to give that engine right back to you.
他对我说了，你为了一个轻便摩托车引擎追到监狱里来了？我说，是的。我从13岁起就有了，它对我意义重大。我想让它发动起来。他说，是的，我有。他非常帮忙，人很好。他给了我地址。他说，你告诉他是我让你去的。告诉他你去监狱看过我。让他把引擎立刻还给你。
They got along so well, Nunzio ended up staying and chatting, he says, for close to an hour. And when he went and retrieved the engine, it was still in the original cardboard box he'd left it in. For everything he'd been told on the phone that they were working on it, it's nearly done, just a little more, he saw nobody had ever touched it.
他们谈得很投机，Nunzio最后留下来聊了将近一个小时，他说。当他去取回引擎时，它还装在他当初留下的那个原始纸箱里。尽管电话里一直跟他说正在修理，快修好了，再等等，他却发现根本没人动过。
I found and talked to the guy that Nunzio remembers, the repair shop owner. And for the record, he remembers none of these events from 20 years ago. And at first, he insisted that none of it ever possibly could have happened, but then talked a little more. He relented a little and said, maybe it did.
我找到了Nunzio记忆中的那个修理店老板，并跟他谈了。记录在案的是，他不记得20年前发生的任何这些事。起初，他坚称这些事根本不可能发生过，但随后谈得多了些。他稍微松口说，也许确实发生过。
Nunzio told me that once he got the scooter engine back, he took a year meticulously rebuilding it himself to bring the whole bike back to cherry condition. This project he decided to take on in 1975 he finally finished three decades later. So much work. I had to ask--
Nunzio告诉我，当他拿回轻便摩托车引擎后，他花了一年时间细致地亲手修复它，让整辆车恢复到最佳状态。他决定在1975年启动的这个项目，最终在三十年后完成了。太辛苦了。我不得不问——
It's been 20 years. How many times do you think you've ridden it in 20 years?
已经20年了。你觉得这20年来你骑过多少次？
Oh. I mean, 30? 40?
噢。我的意思是，30次？40次？
That doesn't sound like a lot.
听起来并不多。
No, it's not.
不，确实不多。
The point of the bike was not riding it. Some objects have a power over us that's special. They make us do crazy stuff, stuff we probably wouldn't do for another person, for years sometimes. Today on our show, we have stories of people caught in that kind of servile relationship with objects that they supposedly own. But in each of these stories, as you'll hear, the objects seem to be the ones calling the shots. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这辆车的意义不在于骑它。有些物品对我们有一种特殊的力量。它们让我们去做疯狂的事，甚至是我们可能不会为了另一个人去做的事，有时甚至坚持多年。今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述人们陷入那种与他们声称拥有的物品之间卑微关系的故事。但在每一个故事中，正如你将听到的那样，物品似乎才是真正做主的那一方。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, A Rock and a Hard Place. So let's start today with an object that a guy got a long time ago that first meant one thing to him, and then it came to mean something very different and much more important. Aviva DeKornfeld talked to the guy and has this story.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，进退维谷。那么今天我们就从一个人很久以前得到的一个物品开始讲起，它起初对他意义非凡，后来却变得非常不同，也重要得多。Aviva DeKornfeld采访了那个人，带来了这个故事。
When Ted was six years old, his mom had just remarried, and his new dad had this idea for all of them to go on their first big trip as a family, a road trip.
当Ted六岁时，他的母亲刚再婚，他的继父有个主意，让他们全家去进行第一次盛大的家庭旅行，一次公路旅行。
He thought it would be cool to take the family on a trip out west. And we stopped at every attraction. We went to the Painted Desert, the Grand Canyon. And we also went to see the crater in Arizona.
他觉得带全家去西部旅行会很酷。我们在每个景点都停了下来。我们去了彩色沙漠、大峡谷。我们还去看了亚利桑那州的陨石坑。
Ah, cool.
啊，酷。
So it was a huge time for us. I mean, for me personally, it was like the first experience I remember going anywhere.
所以那对我们来说是一段美好的时光。我是说，对我个人而言，那是我记得去任何地方的第一次经历。
The important stop for our story? The Petrified Forest National Park.
我们故事的重要一站？石化林国家公园。
I remember driving through the forest. And I just-- I don't know. I was that age where I flipped out over everything.
我记得开车穿过森林。我就是——我不知道。我正处于那种会对所有事情大惊小怪的年纪。
Petrified wood is kind of worth flipping out over. It's crazy to look at because it looks like a tree. You can see the texture of the bark and the grain of the wood and the tree rings, but it's a rock. Plus, in the process of becoming a rock over millions of years, the wood gets this rainbow coloring from all the mineral deposits. So it looks kind of magical.
硅化木确实值得大惊小怪。它看起来很神奇，因为它看起来像一棵树。你可以看到树皮的纹理、木材的纹理和年轮，但它是一块石头。此外，在历经数百万年变成石头的过程中，木头因所有的矿物质沉积而呈现出彩虹般的颜色。所以它看起来有点神奇。
I remember seeing an area that we went to where there were a bunch of different trees laying on the ground, like all in a row. And I remember begging my dad, please, you know? And so I guess I bugged my dad enough that he finally let me pick a piece. I got to pick it. And of course, I picked a big chunk.
我记得去过一个地方，地上躺着许多不同的树，排成一排。我记得央求我父亲，求求你了，好吗？我想我磨了他够久，他终于让我挑了一块。我可以选。当然，我选了一块很大的。
How big was it?
它有多大？
It was significant.
很大。
Like the size of a baseball? Is that what we're talking about?
像棒球那么大吗？我们在说那个吗？
Yeah. Probably more like the size of a football.
是的。大概更像是橄榄球那么大。
Oh. Really big.
噢。真的很大。
Yeah, yeah. It's pretty hefty. And I remember my dad pulling it out of the spot it was in, you know? So now that tree had a chunk missing.
是的，是的。相当沉。我记得我父亲把它从原来的地方拔了出来，你知道吧？所以那棵树现在少了一块。
Ted's dad was the kind of guy who would bend the rules for his kids.
Ted的父亲是那种会为孩子打破规则的人。
So I remember him saying, OK, well, we're going to put it in the trunk, but don't say anything when we go through the gate, you know?
所以我记得他说，好吧，我们把它放进后备箱，但当我们通过大门时别吱声，你知道吗？
'Cause you knew you weren't allowed to take it.
因为你知道你不被允许拿走它。
Yeah. We hid it in the trunk, under some clothes. I remember when we got to the hotel that night, we unwrapped it and brought it into the hotel room. I mean, he didn't have to do that, but he made a big deal out of it. And, yeah, I remember my mom writing a postcard to my aunt saying that Teddy-- that's what they called me, Teddy. Teddy got a piece of petrified wood from the forest. And then, after that, when we got home, I really didn't think about it much.
是的。我们把它藏在后备箱，衣服下面。我记得那天晚上到了酒店，我们打开包装把它带进房间。我是说，他本不必这么做，但他把这件事搞得很隆重。是的，我记得我母亲写了一张明信片寄给我阿姨，说Teddy——他们这么叫我，Teddy。Teddy从森林里得到了一块硅化木。然后，在那之后，当我们回到家时，我就没怎么想过这件事。
Until, one day, over 40 years later--
直到有一天，40多年后——
My daughter said, hey, she's a senior in high school. She comes in the kitchen, and she says, hey, Dad, that rock out in the garden, is that a petrified wood? I said, yeah. And she said, where did you get that? And I said, I told her the story. When I was a kid, we went to the Petrified Forest, and I took it. She says, that's what I thought. She says, I found this interesting article online, and it says that people who have taken petrified wood are cursed, which I-- a light bulb went off. I was like, this could be it.
我女儿说，嘿，她是高四学生。她走进厨房，说，嘿，爸，花园里的那块石头是硅化木吗？我说，是的。她说，你是从哪弄来的？我说，我告诉了她这个故事。我小时候，我们去了石化林，我拿了它。她说，我就知道。她说，我在网上看到一篇有趣的文章，上面说拿走硅化木的人会受到诅咒，我——灵光一闪。我想，可能就是这样。
The idea that this petrified wood may have cursed him? This made a lot of sense to Ted because he thought he'd been cursed for years. For as long as he could remember, he'd had very bad luck, no matter where he was or what he did.
这种硅化木可能诅咒了他的想法，对Ted来说很有道理，因为他觉得自己多年来一直被诅咒。从他记事起，他的运气就一直很差，无论他在哪里或做什么。
Couldn't catch a break. Could not catch a break.
从来没走过运。真的从来没走过运。
The bad luck found him when he was at home.
厄运在他家时也跟着他。
We had a house fire when my daughter was two years old. When she was three years old, the eye of Hurricane Katrina passed over our city in Mississippi and put 6 feet of water in our house.
我女儿两岁时我们家发生了火灾。她三岁时，卡特里娜飓风的眼经过我们所在的密西西比州的城市，导致我们家里进了6英尺深的水。
The bad luck followed him abroad, too.
厄运也跟着他到了国外。
I got a bad infection in El Salvador and lost my hearing in one side.
我在萨尔瓦多得了严重的感染，导致我一边听力丧失。
When Ted went hunting for bird nests with his friends--
当Ted和朋友们去掏鸟窝时——
We're in the middle of the woods. I fell on a broken root beer bottle. It was like there was nothing else around. And I cut my hand open. I still have a scar.
我们在树林中间。我摔在了一个破碎的根啤酒瓶上。感觉周围什么别的东西都没有。我的手被割开了。我至今还有疤。
There's more.
还有更多。
I hit a deer driving through San Antonio full-on and totaled my car.
我开车穿过圣安东尼奥时正面撞上了一头鹿，我的车报废了。
Oh, and the bad luck came for his love life, too. His marriage started falling apart.
噢，厄运也找上了他的感情生活。他的婚姻开始破裂。
I think that's pretty unlucky.
我觉得那真的很倒霉。
Are there other things?
还有别的事吗？
Yeah, of course. I can give you 6, 10, 12 examples, whatever you want. It's something that was with me always. It followed me everywhere. It was a scourge on my life. It was a shadow that was always with me. If something bad could happen, it would happen.
当然。我可以给你举6个、10个、12个例子，随你挑。这东西一直跟着我。它跟着我去了任何地方。它是生活中的一场灾难。它是我身边的一道阴影。如果有什么坏事可能发生，它一定会发生。
Is it possible that that's just stuff that happened to you and not that you were cursed?
有没有可能那只是发生在你身上的事情，而不是你被诅咒了？
I think no. No. I was cursed, 100%. You can ask my friends and family. It was an ongoing joke, you know? You got to call it like you see it. I'm a realist. Seeing is believing. So if you see a vase on the table, there's a vase on the table. Right? I was cursed. I saw it.
我觉得不。不。我被诅咒了，百分之百。你可以问我的朋友和家人。这成了个持续不断的笑话，你知道吧？事实就是事实。我是个现实主义者。眼见为实。所以如果你看到桌上有一个花瓶，桌上就有一个花瓶。对吧？我被诅咒了。我看到了。
So for decades, Ted lived in fear of the next bad thing happening. And then his daughter told him about that article she'd found.
所以几十年来，Ted一直活在对下一件坏事发生的恐惧中。后来他女儿告诉了他她发现的那篇文章。
I couldn't believe it. I read the article. I was like, holy cow, this could be it, you know? And I read the story, and I was like, oh my God, I didn't realize that I did such a bad thing.
我简直不敢相信。我读了那篇文章。我当时想，天哪，可能就是这个，你知道吧？我读了那个故事，我想，天啊，我没想到我做了这么糟糕的事。
Well, you were so little.
好吧，你当时太小了。
Yeah, I was real little. But I guess that doesn't matter when it comes to something like a curse, right? I mean, there's no age limit on it.
是的，我真的很小。但我猜当涉及诅咒这种事时，这并不重要，对吧？我是说，这没有年龄限制。
It's unclear where exactly this idea that petrified rocks curse people came from. I tried to run it down, but no one knows. And it didn't matter to Ted anyway. All he knew was that he was cursed, and he needed to get that wood back to the park as soon as possible. Handily, he happened to be working at the post office at the time. So the next day, he went to work and grabbed a priority box, flat rate because the rock was so heavy.
不清楚硅化岩会诅咒人的想法究竟从何而来。我试图追查，但没人知道。反正这对Ted来说也不重要。他只知道他被诅咒了，他需要尽快把那块木头送回公园。凑巧的是，他当时正在邮局工作。所以第二天，他去上班拿了一个优先配送箱，固定费率，因为那块石头太重了。
Yeah, my daughter told me, hey, you should write a letter. You should apologize for it. Whatever you have to do, you have to end your curse. So I said, I will. I'll write the letter, you know?
是的，我女儿告诉我，嘿，你应该写封信。你应该道歉。无论你需要做什么，你必须结束你的诅咒。所以我说，我会的。我会写那封信，你知道吧？
Ted carefully swaddled the petrified wood in bubble wrap to protect it and placed it in a box, along with his letter. It cost him $22 to ship, a steal if it breaks the curse.
Ted小心翼翼地用气泡膜包裹住硅化木以保护它，并把它放进盒子里，随信附上。寄送花了他22美元，如果能打破诅咒，这简直是捡了大便宜。
The Petrified Forest National Park has a long history with rock thieves like Ted. In fact, that's why they became a national park in the first place. Local residents worried about the area being totally stripped and petitioned to turn the land into a park to protect it. Years ago, there was a study that found they could be losing wood at a rate of 12 tons per year. And so, for decades, the park tried all kinds of tactics to discourage theft-- vehicle inspections, fines, supervised tours, preemptively gifting people a little piece of wood bought from private land near the park. You might think that park rangers invented the curse as a deterrent, but no.
石化林国家公园处理像Ted这样的窃岩贼有很长的历史。事实上，这就是他们起初成为国家公园的原因。当地居民担心该地区被彻底剥夺，并请愿将这片土地变成公园以保护它。多年前，一项研究发现，他们每年可能流失12吨木头。因此，几十年来，公园尝试了各种战术来阻止盗窃——车辆检查、罚款、有监督的旅游、预先赠送人们从公园附近私有土地购买的小块木头。你可能会认为公园管理员发明了这个诅咒作为威慑，但并没有。
But somehow, word spread, making Ted just one of hundreds of people who have sent pieces of petrified wood back to the park. Matt Smith, the ranger in charge of processing the returned rocks, says that a rock arrives roughly once a week, often with a letter attached. There are now over a thousand letters in their archive.
但不知何故，消息传开了，这让Ted成为数百名将硅化木碎片寄回公园的人之一。负责处理退回岩石的管理员Matt Smith说，大约每周都会收到一块石头，通常附有一封信。他们的档案中现在有超过一千封信。
It seemed strange to me. So many people all came to believe their bad luck came from a rock and felt compelled not just to return the rock, but to apologize and explain themselves? I wanted to read the letters for myself, so I flew out to the park in Arizona. Ranger Matt set me up with a desk and plopped down two big boxes stuffed with letters. I spent a full day sifting through them.
这对我来说似乎很奇怪。这么多人竟然都相信他们的坏运气来自一块石头，不仅感到被迫归还石头，还要道歉并解释自己？我想亲自读读这些信，所以我飞往亚利桑那州的公园。管理员Matt给了我一张桌子，放下了两个装满信件的大箱子。我花了一整天翻阅它们。
The first letter the park ever received was from a guy in India in 1935. From there, the letters are organized by year, mostly handwritten. The letters have a kind of frenzied urgency to them, like this one-- "Please release me. My life is hell," or this one-- which is oddly accusatory, considering they're the thief-- "You should tell people these are cursed before people take them. Sorry."
公园收到的第一封信来自1935年印度的一名男子。从那时起，信件按年份整理，大多是手写的。信件中有一种疯狂的紧迫感，比如这一封——“请释放我。我的生活如地狱一般，”或者这一封——考虑到他们是小偷，这封信显得异常咄咄逼人——“你应该在人们拿走前告诉他们这些东西被诅咒了。抱歉。”
But lots of people go to great lengths to detail their woes, pages and pages that feel more like a journal entry than federal mail. The list of hardships attributed to the rocks are wide-ranging, including, but not limited to, layoffs, car accidents, robberies, cancer, divorce. A lot of beloved family dogs died. One guy had a failed vasectomy. Another fell through the ceiling of his house.
但很多人竭尽全力详述他们的苦难，几页几页的内容感觉更像是日记条目而非联邦邮件。归咎于岩石的苦难清单涵盖范围很广，包括但不限于失业、车祸、抢劫、癌症、离婚。许多心爱的家庭狗死了。一个人输精管结扎失败。另一个人从屋顶摔了下来。
And one person's fiancé cheated on them with a Norwegian woman. There are a lot of mentions of idiot husbands and apologies on their behalf and tons of people who didn't even take the rocks themselves, but somehow looked at their lives and concluded that everything bad happened because of the rocks their parents or grandparents had stolen, like a weird, petrified version of inherited trauma.
还有人的未婚妻和一个挪威女人出轨了。信中多次提到蠢丈夫，还有替他们道歉的，还有成堆的人甚至自己没拿石头，但不知何故审视了自己的生活，得出结论认为一切坏事发生都是因为他们父母或祖父母偷走的石头，就像某种奇怪的硅化版代际创伤。
One woman sent back a rock with a letter in the hopes of restoring her luck and then promptly sent another letter after she'd realized she'd sent in the wrong rock. In some letters, desperate people describe the ways in which their lives have been horrifically derailed. And then, at the bottom of the letter, a park ranger who's examined the rock has written a little note in pencil-- "Wood not from park." Brutal.
一位女士寄回一块石头并附信希望恢复好运，结果发现寄错了石头后，又匆忙寄了另一封信。在一些信中，绝望的人描述了他们的生活如何惨遭脱轨。然后，在信的底部，检查过岩石的公园管理员用铅笔写了一行小字——“木头非公园所有。”太残忍了。
What's striking about reading so many of these letters back to back is how terrible and ordinary the pain they're recounting is. They're describing all the awful parts of life, the parts you know intellectually are on the table, but still feel shocking when they happen to you. I can imagine what a relief it could be to discover you'd been cursed. Because how nice would it be to get an explanation for why it's all so difficult? Plus, it means you just might have the power to undo it.
连续阅读这么多信件，最引人注目的是他们所叙述的痛苦是多么可怕而普通。他们描述了生活的所有糟糕部分，那些你在理智上知道会发生，但发生在你身上时仍然感到震惊的部分。我可以想象发现自己被诅咒可能是一种解脱。因为如果能为一切为何如此艰难找到解释，那该多好啊？而且，这意味着你可能还有能力去扭转它。
I talked to a few different rangers about this phenomenon, people stealing and returning their rocks. And they were all surprisingly blasé about the whole thing. They don't want people to steal rocks, obviously, but it turns out the amount they're losing every year really isn't that big of a deal. Over time, they figured out that they're not actually losing 12 tons of wood per year.
我和几位不同的管理员谈过这个现象，关于人们偷窃和归还岩石。他们对整件事都表现得异常冷静。显然，他们不希望人们偷岩石，但结果显示，他们每年损失的数量其实并没有那么严重。随着时间的推移，他们发现他们每年并没有真的损失12吨木头。
Plus, people returning rocks? That's just more work for them. The rangers can't determine where exactly in the park the rocks came from, so all the returned rocks just get tossed into a pile. Ranger Matt took me to see it. It's big, maybe 15 feet wide, a few feet tall, with rocks of all sizes.
而且，人们归还岩石？那只会给他们增加更多工作。管理员无法确定岩石究竟来自公园的哪个地方，所以所有退回的岩石都被扔进了一个堆里。管理员Matt带我去看了那个堆。它很大，大约15英尺宽，几英尺高，堆着各种大小的岩石。
How many individual rocks do you think are in this pile?
你觉得这里堆了多少块独立的石头？
No idea. I guess if I had-- I don't know-- 20,000, 50,000, something like that. People are crazy.
不知道。我猜如果我有——我不知道——2万、5万，大概这么多吧。人们真是疯了。
Look at this one.
看这一块。
I know. [LAUGHS]
我知道。[笑声]
If I were going to steal a rock, I would take that one.
如果我要偷一块石头，我会拿那块。
The little pretty ones.
那些漂亮的小石头。
I won't, though, because it's really not a good time for me to be cursed.
不过我不会，因为现在对我来说被诅咒真的不是时候。
No, no. Nobody wants to be cursed.
不，不。没人想被诅咒。
Yeah. Have you ever gotten a letter from someone after they returned the rock saying that the bad luck and the curse had been lifted?
是的。你有没有收到过某人在退还石头后写来的信，说坏运气和诅咒已经解除了？
No. No, I never have. God, I never even thought of that. No, nobody's written back and been like, hey, by the way, everything's better now. I mean, if it is for them, I love that.
没有。没有，我从没收到过。天哪，我甚至从没想过这一点。没有，没有人写信回来说，嘿，顺便说一下，一切都变好了。我是说，如果对他们而言确实如此，我很乐意看到。
I wanted to ask, did anything change after you sent the rock back?
我想问，你寄回石头后有什么改变吗？
I got so lucky that I can't even talk about it.
我运气好到没法形容。
Actually, he could. Couldn't resist. After Ted returned the rock, he came into a lot of money unexpectedly. He also stumbled into a great, below-market-rate deal on a house. He did get divorced, but that, too, felt like good luck. Ted doesn't know for sure if returning the rock is what changed his luck because that was actually just one part of a much broader reckoning for him.
事实上，他能形容。他忍不住了。Ted退还石头后，意外获得了一大笔钱。他还偶然以低于市场的价格买到了一栋房子。他确实离婚了，但那也感觉像是好运。Ted不确定是不是归还石头改变了他的运气，因为那实际上只是他生活发生更广泛转折的一部分。
But whatever it was, he says it worked. These days, his luck has turned around so much that his whole job is based on having good luck. He goes to estate sales and flea markets looking for treasures and sells them online. Like this one time, he was poking around at a sale in an old house and found an old cool-looking duck call.
但不管是什么，他说这奏效了。如今，他的运气好转了很多，他的全部工作都是基于好运气。他去参加遗产拍卖和跳蚤市场寻找宝藏，并在网上出售。比如有一次，他在旧房子的拍卖会上闲逛，发现了一个看起来很酷的旧鸭哨。
You know, for hunting, a duck call? You know, [QUACKS], you blow into it.
你知道，用来狩猎的鸭哨？你知道的，[嘎嘎声]，你对着它吹。
He bought it for $9 and posted it to a hunting Facebook group. Within an hour, he got a message from a guy who said, call me right away. So Ted did.
他以9美元买下并发布在了一个狩猎Facebook群组里。不到一小时，他收到一个人的消息说，立刻给我打电话。Ted照做了。
He said, this is a very special duck call. I'm a collector. And he said, I'm willing to give you $5,000.
他说，这是一个非常特别的鸭哨。我是收藏家。他说，我愿意给你5000美元。
Oh, my God. You started this story cursed and now you're just riding your good luck.
噢，天哪。你开始这个故事时是被诅咒的，现在你简直是好运连连。
Yeah, pretty much. I think so.
是的，差不多。我想是吧。
These days, Ted feels better in all kinds of ways, like things have been put right in his life, like the rock, which is back where it belongs. He'd felt guilty about taking it. That's true for a lot of people. The vast majority of the hundreds of letters I read mentioned guilt. Most people felt bad about having done the wrong thing and just wanted to try and make it right.
这些天，Ted在各方面都感觉更好，就像他生活中的事情得到了纠正，就像那块石头，已经回到了它所属的地方。他为拿走它感到内疚。这对很多人来说都是真的。我读过的数百封信中绝大多数都提到了内疚。大多数人对做了错事感到难受，只是想试图弥补。
A lot of the letters come from people at the end of their lives, doing a little psychic housekeeping before they go. Some of the letters are so simple. Like, what else can I say? I was wrong, and I'm sorry. Or, I don't regret much, but I regret taking this rock. I found Ted's letter in the archive, too, handwritten. He says, "I pray that the return will deem forgiveness from God, the Petrified Forest National Park, and the people of the United States of America." And he apologizes.
很多信件来自生命尽头的人，在离去前做一些心理打扫。有些信很简单。比如，我还能说什么呢？我错了，我很抱歉。或者，我没后悔什么，但我后悔拿了这块石头。我也在档案里找到了Ted的手写信。他写道，“我祈祷这次归还能得到上帝、石化林国家公园以及美国人民的宽恕。”他并表达了歉意。
That big pile of returned rocks, the rangers have a name for it. It's called the Conscience Pile, which I find kind of moving. We make mistakes, and so often, our attempts to make things right fall short. But I think if you're the kind of person who takes the time to mail a rock back to a national park years after taking it, you're probably on the right track.
那一大堆归还的岩石，管理员们给它起了一个名字。叫做“良心堆”，我觉得这有点感人。我们犯错，往往我们试图补救的尝试都会落空。但我认为，如果你是那种会在拿走岩石多年后花时间把它寄回国家公园的人，你可能已经走在正确的道路上了。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our program. Thanks to Ryan Thompson, who noticed some of the letters on display on a trip to the park and then made a book of the letters called Bad Luck, Hot Rocks. That's how we first heard about the story. Coming up, Jonathan Goldstein leaps in to help a family who are not entirely sure they want or need his help with the stuff they own. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Aviva DeKornfeld是我们节目的制作人之一。感谢Ryan Thompson，他在一次去公园的旅行中注意到了展示的信件，然后把它们编成了一本书，叫《坏运气，烫手的岩石》。这就是我们第一次听到这个故事的方式。接下来，Jonathan Goldstein跳出来帮助一个家庭，他们并不完全确定是否想要或需要他帮助他们处理拥有的东西。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续播出后的一分钟内进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Thing About Things, stories of objects that, in one way or another, become our bosses. It's like we are doing their bidding. It's like we're working for them. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, A Few Hundred of My Favorite Things.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，《关于东西的事》，讲述那些以某种方式成为我们老板的物品的故事。就好像我们在执行它们的旨意。就好像我们在为它们工作。我们现在进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，几百件我最喜欢的物品。
Sometimes our attachment to things can be a real problem. You definitely can get too attached. Jonathan Goldstein is a longtime contributor to our show. His own show, Heavyweight, is back now with new episodes after a long hiatus. And one of the new episodes is about some parents whose stuff has become a problem for their kids. As always, on Heavyweight, Jonathan jumps in to help.
有时我们对物品的依恋会成为一个真正的问题。你确实可能陷得太深。Jonathan Goldstein是我们节目的长期撰稿人。他自己的节目《重磅》（Heavyweight）在长期中断后又回来了，带着新的剧集。其中一集是关于一些家长的东西成了他们孩子的问题。一如既往，在《重磅》中，Jonathan跳出来帮忙。
What I love about this particular story is how it unfolds over time-- over years, actually-- and then arrives at the end at these moments that-- I don't know. I don't want to say too much about this. You should just hear them. Here's Jonathan's story.
关于这个特别的故事，我喜欢的是它是如何随时间展开的——实际上是几年——然后在最后达到了这些时刻，这些——我不知道。我不想对此说太多。你们应该亲自听听。这是Jonathan的故事。
[CLEARS THROAT] All right. You ready? You're rolling? You got levels? Mi, mi, ma, ma, moo. OK, go.
[清嗓子] 好了。准备好了吗？开始录音了吗？音量够吗？Mi, mi, ma, ma, moo。好的，开始吧。
This is Gregor. Gregor is one of my oldest friends. And today, he's coming to me with a problem.
这是Gregor。Gregor是我最老的朋友之一。今天，他带着一个问题来找我。
I'll take it from the top. OK, so I have two parents, Milton and Etta.
我从头开始讲。好的，我有两个父母，Milton和Etta。
Etta and Milton are both pushing 90. And Gregor's problem is that they refuse to move out of their house. It's the same three-story Victorian Gregor grew up in. He was 12 when the family first moved in. He still remembers the excitement as they unloaded boxes from the moving truck or moving trucks.
Etta和Milton都快90岁了。Gregor的问题是他们拒绝搬离他们的房子。那是Gregor从小长大的同一栋三层维多利亚式住宅。他们家第一次搬进去时他才12岁。他仍然记得他们从搬家货车卸下箱子时的兴奋劲儿。
Normal people move with a big, giant 18-wheeler moving truck. I believe when we moved, we had six moving trucks.
正常人用一辆巨大的18轮搬家大货车搬家。我相信我们搬家时，用了六辆搬家货车。
One for the family's belongings. The other five? For the collections. Some people collect coins. Some people collect comic books. Gregor's mother, Etta, collects collections.
一辆装家人的财物。其他五辆？装收藏品。有些人收集硬币。有些人收集漫画书。Gregor的母亲Etta收集的是收藏品本身。
She has, like, maybe 200 egg beaters, antique egg beaters. She has-- do you know what a bisque nodder is?
她有，大概200个打蛋器，古董打蛋器。她有——你知道什么是点头瓷偶吗？
No.
不知道。
[CHUCKLES] In occupied Japan, people bought these little figurines where the head would wobble back and forth.
[笑声] 在被占领的日本，人们买这些小人像，头会来回摇晃。
Like a bobbleheaded doll?
像摇头娃娃吗？
Something like that. Anyway, she probably has 2,000 bisque nodders.
差不多。总之，她可能有2000个点头瓷偶。
Then there are the 19th century weaving looms, the handmade baskets, the medieval scythes. Etta Ehrlich is an artist, and her collections are the source of her inspiration. Etta sees beauty in everything. And in her hands, everything becomes art. She'll sculpt lint from the dryer. She'll put googly eyes on a splatter of dried bird poop.
还有19世纪的织布机、手工篮子、中世纪的镰刀。Etta Ehrlich是一位艺术家，她的收藏是她灵感的来源。Etta在所有东西中都能看到美。在她的手中，所有东西都成了艺术。她会雕刻烘干机里的绒毛。她会给一摊干掉的鸟屎贴上可动眼珠。
My mother has been unbelievably prolific in making art for the last 35 years, to a degree where now the living room is, like, full to the brim with a million pieces of art. And every week, she probably makes five or 10 more pieces of art.
过去35年来，我母亲在创作艺术方面高产得惊人，现在起居室简直装满了上百万件艺术品。而且每周，她大概还会再创作五到十件艺术品。
None of this would be a problem, except that a large, cluttered house is becoming increasingly dangerous for Gregor's elderly parents.
如果不是因为一栋又大又杂乱的房子对Gregor年迈的父母变得越来越危险，这一切都不会是个问题。
I fear the more conventional fears. I fear my mother falling down a flight of stairs-- or my father. I mean, there's all kinds of dark things that can happen in a house full of staircases.
我担心更常规的恐惧。我担心我母亲摔下楼梯——或者我父亲。我是说，房子里满是楼梯，各种暗藏的危险都有可能发生。
And so Gregor wants to move his parents into a smaller apartment, something more manageable. That's his plan.
所以Gregor想把他父母搬进一个小点的公寓，更容易管理一些。那是他的计划。
Yeah, that's his plan. But that's not my plan.
是的，那是他的计划。但这可不是我的计划。
This is Etta.
这是Etta。
The practical thing is, we can't be in the house too much longer. I'm 88.
实际情况是，我们不能在房子里待太久了。我88岁了。
Yeah.
是的。
But to move out of the house isn't simply a question of selling the furniture. It's, my god, what do we do with all this?
但搬离房子不仅仅是卖掉家具的问题。天哪，我们拿这些东西怎么办？
All this, all the collections is what's keeping Etta in the house. And of all her many collections, of all her milking stools and antique rolling pins, it's her collection of fragile, colorful bottles that is perhaps the biggest impediment to moving. By Gregor's estimate, Etta has thousands-- wine bottles, perfume bottles, old decanters, bottles washed up from the bottom of the ocean. As well as being an artist, Etta is a Buddhist. And her bottles are not just bottles, but a series of meditations. Because on each of the bottles, in fancy fonts and careful calligraphy, Etta places a message in the form of a zen-like riddle.
所有这些东西，所有的收藏品，正是把Etta困在房子里的东西。在她众多的收藏中，在她所有的挤奶凳和古董擀面杖中，她收集的那些易碎、色彩鲜艳的瓶子可能是搬迁最大的阻碍。根据Gregor的估计，Etta有成千上万个——葡萄酒瓶、香水瓶、旧醒酒器、从海底冲刷上岸的瓶子。除了作为艺术家，Etta还是个佛教徒。她的瓶子不仅是瓶子，而是一系列冥想。因为在每一个瓶子上，Etta都用花哨的字体和认真的书法写下了一条禅意的谜题。
"I turn my noose to tightrope use and madly dance upon it." Isn't that gorgeous?
“我把套索变成紧绳，在上面疯狂起舞。” 这不是很美吗？
That's very nice.
那很好。
There you go. You want me to give that away for nothing?
看，就是这样。你想让我白白送人吗？
Other inscriptions are "Stop schlepping your old being into the future," or, "We cling to illusions of control." After hearing a few, I start to recognize a theme. All the bottles bear messages imploring one to let go. Yet Etta is incapable of letting go of the very bottles doing the imploring, or much of anything else.
其他铭文是“别把你旧的自我拖进未来”，或者，“我们执着于控制的幻觉”。听了几个之后，我开始识别出一个主题。所有的瓶子都带着请求人们放下的信息。然而Etta却无法放下那些要求放下的瓶子，或者其他任何东西。
There is a little bit of a paradox, or there's something to--
这确实有点矛盾，或者说有点……
Yes.
是的。
--kind of be struggling with here.
……需要在这里纠结一下。
Jonathan, you're very, very sharp. That is exactly, exactly true. These works, which talk about being stuck with the grasping level, I suffer from that.
Jonathan，你真的很敏锐。那完全、完全正确。这些作品，讨论着被执着所困，我也深受其害。
I could leave tomorrow.
我可以明天就走。
This is Gregor's dad, Milt.
这是Gregor的父亲Milt。
If the taxi pulled up right now, you would jump in.
如果现在出租车开过来，你就会跳进去。
I'm ready to go. Yeah.
我准备好走了。是的。
I'll stop you there. He's never taken a taxi in his life. But if I pulled up right now-- I'm kidding.
我在这儿打断一下。他这辈子从没打过出租车。但如果我现在开过来——我在开玩笑。
Uber duber. I don't get attached to furniture and bottles and stuff.
Uber什么的。我不会对家具、瓶子之类的东西产生依恋。
I'll just reinforce that point that while my father may posit that he's a daoist and not attached to anything, he is very much complicit to relentlessly bring home the raw material to which my mother turns the art out.
我得重申一点，虽然我父亲可能认为他是道家，对任何东西都不依恋，但他却非常共谋，无休止地把原材料带回家，让我母亲变成艺术品。
When was the last time you brought something home, Milt?
Milt，你上次带东西回家是什么时候？
Yesterday. [LAUGHS] I'm always interested in what she's doing. And I often find the raw materials. Walking around in the woods or anywhere, I find stuff. Her only requirement is if I find something, it has to have what she calls charm. [LAUGHS]
昨天。[笑声] 我一直对她做的事感兴趣。我经常找到原材料。在树林里或任何地方走动，我都能找到东西。她唯一的要求是，如果我找到东西，它必须具备她所谓的魅力。[笑声]
As for Milt, what he's charmed by, exceedingly charmed by, is Etta. Milt is a poet, and after over 60 years of marriage, he still writes poems about her, rhapsodizing about the way she creates art or cooks or the way she dances. Milt says he can watch Etta dance all night. He just doesn't understand her being so chained to her belongings.
至于Milt，他迷恋的，极其迷恋的，是Etta。Milt是一位诗人，结婚60多年后，他仍然写关于她的诗，狂热地赞美她创作艺术、做饭或跳舞的方式。Milt说他可以整晚看Etta跳舞。他只是不明白她为什么要被自己的所有物锁得那么死。
I'm stuck. But I am not coming up with a solution that's any better, am I?
我被困住了。但我并没有想出什么更好的解决方案，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah? Except dying. And-- [LAUGHS] you know?
是的？除了死。还有——[笑声] 你知道的？
That's not a solution.
那不是解决办法。
No, it's not a solution for Greg. He's left holding the whole thing.
不，对Greg来说那不是解决办法。他被留下来承担这一切。
Of Milton and his three kids, Gregor is perhaps the one most ready to serve, the child his parents hand a to-do list when he comes to visit.
在Milton的三个孩子中，Gregor可能是最乐于助人的一个，是他父母在来看望时塞给清单的孩子。
I mean, he talks mean. And that's because he has meanness in him. [LAUGHS] I'm not saying he doesn't. But he's also a very kind, giving, generous, loving person.
我是说，他说话刻薄。那是因为他骨子里有刻薄。[笑声] 我不是说他没有。但他也非常善良、慷慨、大方、有爱心。
Yes, he is. Yeah.
是的，他是。是的。
Yeah. Don't tell him I said so. [LAUGHS]
是的。别告诉他我这么说了。[笑声]
Inaction is a choice. Not doing anything, something's bound to happen sooner or later. And to just watch the second hand sweep around the clock face until somebody is dead is the most passive and weakest possible way to exist and die. It just feels like the Damoclean sword of mortality is coming. And all we're going to do is sit here and watch Rachel Maddow until it cuts our head off.
不作为也是一种选择。什么都不做，迟早会出事。眼睁睁看着秒针绕着钟面转直到有人死去，这是存在和死去最被动、最虚弱的方式。感觉就像达摩克利斯之剑即将落下。而我们所做的只是坐在这里看Rachel Maddow直到它砍掉我们的头。
And so because Etta can't let go, Gregor wants my help in pulling off a most extravagant workaround, one that will allow Etta to both keep her stuff and still move out. The plan of action that Gregor wants to present to her--
正因为Etta无法放下，Gregor想要我的帮助来完成一个最奢侈的变通方案，一个既能让Etta保留她的东西又能搬离的方案。Gregor想向她提出的行动计划——
What if you don't get rid of your possessions, and we make a museum of your stuff?
如果你不扔掉你的财产，我们把你的东西做成博物馆怎么样？
Gregor explains to me the details. It seems that in the 1960s, Etta and Milt bought a 200-year-old farmhouse with no running water or indoor plumbing. Gregor's plan is to convert the barn into the Etta B. Erlich Museum. Convincing one's mother to downsize by way of a feral farmhouse museum that, by Gregor's own admission, is probably a breeding ground for the hantavirus, has all the makings of a classic cockamamie scheme. But this is just the beginning.
Gregor向我解释了细节。看起来在20世纪60年代，Etta和Milt买了一个有200年历史的农舍，没有自来水或室内管道。Gregor的计划是将谷仓改造成“Etta B. Erlich博物馆”。通过一个估计会让汉坦病毒滋生的废弃农舍博物馆来说服母亲精简生活，这本身就具有经典荒诞方案的所有特征。但这仅仅是个开始。
For his plan to build a museum to work, Gregor will need his siblings on board. So as his emotional envoy, I begin by phoning his sister, Lexi. Lexi is the level-headed one of the three, and I want to get her read on the plan.
为了他建立博物馆的计划能奏效，Gregor需要他的兄弟姐妹支持。所以作为他的情感特使，我先打电话给了他的姐姐Lexi。Lexi是三个人中最清醒的一个，我想听听她对这个计划的看法。
Is it realistic that he'll be able to turn the barn into a museum like that?
他能把谷仓变成那样的博物馆现实吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Perhaps this plan is a bit half-baked, but I figure I might have more luck getting Gregor's brother, Dimitri, on board. Dimitri has never been afraid of a scheme that runs a little pink on the inside.
也许这个计划有点不成熟，但我认为我在让Gregor的兄弟Dimitri支持方面可能会有更多运气。Dimitri从不害怕带点激进色彩的方案。
[LINE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
So I give him a call. We haven't spoken since I moved from New York, where Dimitri lives, to Minnesota.
所以我给他打了个电话。自从我从Dimitri居住的纽约搬到明尼苏达以来，我们就没交谈过。
I hate to see a Minneapolis area code when you call. It makes me sad.
我讨厌看到明尼阿波利斯的区号出现在你的来电里。这让我难过。
Your business doesn't bring you to Minnesota, I'm guessing.
我猜你的生意不会让你来明尼苏达。
It does sometimes. I interviewed Prince for a cover story. Everyone warned me to be very careful with Prince. He's very touchy.
有时候会。我采访过Prince做封面故事。每个人都警告我要对Prince非常小心。他很敏感。
Dimitri is a martial arts instructor who has kickboxed his way across Thailand. He's also a journalist who interviews celebrities--
Dimitri是一位武术教练，曾在泰国踢过拳。他也是一名采访名人的记者——
So I went there and waited all day for the interview.
所以我去了那里，等了一整天采访。
--and a musician who had a song go platinum three times in Belgium.
——还是一名在比利时歌曲获得三次白金唱片的音乐家。
--and was like, hey, you want to jam? And I was like, OK. So I wound up actually jamming with Larry Graham and Prince for like 20 minutes.
——当时就像，嘿，想玩一把吗？我当时就像，好的。所以我最终竟然和Larry Graham还有Prince即兴演奏了20分钟。
[LAUGHS] What?
[笑声] 什么？
That was one time. [LAUGHS]
那是一次。[笑声]
Before Dimitri can launch into his next sentence, I jump in.
在Dimitri开始下一句之前，我插话了。
So your brother, Gregor--
所以，你的兄弟，Gregor——
Yeah, I'm familiar with him.
是的，我很熟悉他。
--he has this plan, which maybe you're all so familiar with.
——他有个计划，也许你们都很熟悉。
When I'm finished rehashing Gregor's museum plan, Dimitri offers a laundry list of issues.
当我重申完Gregor的博物馆计划后，Dimitri列出了一长串问题。
99% to 100% chance of getting Lyme disease walking out of your car to the barn because it's high grass, a lot of deer, getting poison ivy. There's also, like, horrible black mold because as you know, the farmhouse burned down when my albino baker friend, Theo, stayed there and lit a fire, and the roof and the whole house burned down.
从车上走到谷仓有99%到100%的几率得莱姆病，因为那里草很高，有很多鹿，还长毒藤。还有像可怕的黑霉，因为如你所知，我那白化病面包师朋友Theo待在那里点火时，农舍烧毁了，屋顶和整栋房子都被烧毁了。
And along with his friend Theo's trouble, there was also his friend Sonam's trouble in that cursed place.
除了他朋友Theo的麻烦，在那座被诅咒的地方还有他朋友Sonam的麻烦。
My friend, who spent 25 years as a Buddhist monk under the Dalai Lama, had to use a broom to fight off a very large raccoon that was in the house and was growling at us, like a just horrifying feral raccoon--
我的朋友，他在达赖喇嘛座下做了25年佛教僧侣，不得不拿起扫帚与一只房子里非常大的浣熊搏斗，那浣熊还在我们面前咆哮，就像一只令人毛骨悚然的野浣熊——
But for Dimitri, even more daunting than the rabid raccoons is changing his mother's mind on the matter. Whenever he's tried to clear space in his parents' home, it refills overnight, suggesting Etta's problem can't be solved by physical means. Instead, he thinks the problem has to be attacked at its psychological root. She needs to learn how to let go. And for this, Dimitri has just the solution.
但对Dimitri来说，比狂犬病浣熊更令人生畏的是改变母亲的态度。每当他试图清理父母家里的空间时，它在一夜之间就会填满，这表明Etta的问题无法通过物理手段解决。相反，他认为问题必须从心理根源上攻击。她需要学会如何放下。为此，Dimitri正好有一个解决方案。
Well, maybe hypnosis. It stopped her from smoking, which is probably a more powerful psychological and physical addiction than collecting things.
好吧，也许催眠。它让她停止了吸烟，这可能比收集东西是一种更强大的心理和身体成瘾。
Etta was a pack-a-day smoker, a habit she hung on to for nearly 30 years.
Etta曾经每天抽一包烟，这个习惯她维持了近30年。
Our friend, who was a hypnotist, said, oh, I can hypnotize you. And she went into the session thinking, this isn't going to work. The whole time the hypnosis was going on, she was like, this isn't working, this isn't working. And then she walked out and never smoked again.
我们的一个做催眠师的朋友说，噢，我可以催眠你。她去参加治疗时想，这不会奏效。整个催眠过程中，她一直觉得，这没用，这没用。然后她走出来，再也没抽过烟。
Hmm.
嗯。
He was an interesting person, too. His name was Saul Feldstein. He actually had one of his eyeballs was hanging out of his face. And it was like a sort of early commune hippie thing. And like--
他也是个有趣的人。他叫Saul Feldstein。他实际上有一只眼球挂在脸上。那是一种早期的公社嬉皮风。而且像——
Having grown up on TV sitcoms of the 1970s, I'm well aware of the power of hypnosis.
因为是在1970年代电视情景喜剧中长大的，我很清楚催眠的力量。
--hanging out of his face.
——挂在脸上。
Hypnosis gave Fred Flintstone the self-control to stop eating brontosaurus burgers.
催眠给了弗莱德·弗林特斯通停止吃雷龙汉堡的自控力。
--early commune hippie thing.
——早期的公社嬉皮风。
It gave The Fonz the confidence to jump Snake Canyon on his motorcycle.
它给了Fonz跳过蛇峡谷的自信。
One of his eyeballs--
他的一只眼球——
As a boy, I always wondered what it would feel like to have my full potential unlocked through the hypnotic arts.
作为男孩，我一直想知道通过催眠艺术释放全部潜能是什么感觉。
--hanging out of his face, and he was very successful as a hypnotist.
——挂在他的脸上，他作为催眠师非常成功。
Wow.
哇。
Unlike building a museum, hypnosis requires neither time, effort, nor those awful stanchions that snap back with that loud thwacking sound that make everyone turn around and stare at you. Fully convinced that Saul Feldstein is the solution to all of our problems and that museums belong in a museum, Dimitri and I say our goodbyes.
与建立博物馆不同，催眠不需要时间、精力，也不需要那些发出响亮敲击声会弹回来让你转头瞪你的可怕栅栏。完全相信Saul Feldstein是我们所有问题的解决方案，而博物馆应该待在博物馆里，Dimitri和我道别了。
We're slating in on part two, Johnny discusses post-talking to Dimitri. Here we go.
我们正在进入第二部分，Johnny在谈完Dimitri之后讨论。我们开始了。
I need to tell Gregor that I like Dimitri's idea much better than his, but I need to tread lightly. From Cain and Abel to Stephen and Alec Baldwin, I know how competitive brothers can be. And unlike the Lord or Alexander Rae Baldwin, I don't want to be seen playing favorites.
我需要告诉Gregor我喜欢Dimitri的想法远胜过他的，但我需要小心行事。从该隐和亚伯到史蒂芬和亚历克·鲍德温，我知道兄弟间竞争有多强。不像上帝或亚历山大·雷·鲍德温，我不想被看作偏袒谁。
Do you think that hypnotism has a role in this?
你觉得催眠在这里有作用吗？
Well, I hear that your voice went up an octave when we started talking about hypnotism, and you got excited about hypnotism.
好吧，我听说当你开始谈论催眠时，你的声音高了一个八度，而且你对催眠感到兴奋。
Well, Dimitri seemed to think that it could help.
好吧，Dimitri似乎认为那会有帮助。
OK, so the two of you should go see a movie together.
好吧，那么你们两个应该一起去看场电影。
Going to movies is Gregor and my thing. Clearly, I'm arousing some jealousy. I need to keep my arguments away from Dimitri and grounded in the merits of hypnotism.
去看电影是Gregor和我的事情。很明显，我引起了一些嫉妒。我需要把我的论点从Dimitri身上移开，建立在催眠的好处上。
--as the symptom. But through hypnosis--
——作为症状。但通过催眠——
Why are you saying it with the weird accent on the word "hypnosis"?
为什么你在说“催眠”这个词时发音那么奇怪？
I mean, do you think that hypnotism has something to offer here?
我是说，你觉得催眠在这里有什么用吗？
My short answer would be absolutely not. I think it's a waste of time.
我的简短回答是绝对没有。我觉得那是在浪费时间。
[LINE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hypnosis. "Hip-nosis." "Hip-no-sis."
催眠。“Hip-nosis。” “Hip-no-sis。”
Hi, Johnny. How are you?
嗨，Johnny。你好吗？
Hey, Dimitri. Hi. I've got your brother, Gregor, on the line with me.
嘿，Dimitri。嗨。我和你的兄弟Gregor在线。
We've met.
我们见过。
Hi, how are you?
嗨，你好吗？
Can you make the case to your brother?
你能向你兄弟陈述你的理由吗？
Sure. I just think that there's no harm. There's certainly nothing to lose. It takes 15 or 20 minutes. And she's proven that she's very susceptible to hypnotic suggestions. So why not try it?
当然。我只是认为没有坏处。绝对没有什么可失去的。只需要15或20分钟。她已经证明了她非常容易受到催眠暗示的影响。所以为什么不试试呢？
I agree with all those points. My main feeling is that, getting someone to stop a behavior like smoking is much, much easier than getting someone to change their personality, which is harder to hypnotize someone out of.
我同意所有这些观点。我的主要感觉是，让一个人停止像吸烟这样的行为，比改变一个人的性格要容易得多，而要通过催眠让人改变性格更难。
That may be true. I wouldn't disagree there.
这可能是真的。我不会反对这一点。
Swept up in a wave of brotherly bonhomie, I decide it's a safe space to cautiously share my one secret boyhood longing--
在兄弟情谊的浪潮中，我决定这是一个安全空间，小心地分享我那个少年时代的秘密渴望——
And along the way, I could get hypnotized out of something, too.
而且与此同时，我也可以通过催眠改掉点什么。
Yeah, a lot stuff.
是的，很多东西。
Yeah.
是的。
--and immediately regret it.
——并立即后悔了。
What do you mean, a lot of stuff?
你说的“很多东西”是什么意思？
I mean, that smug smile they could work on.
我是说，那个他们可以改掉的沾沾自喜的微笑。
We could give you a whole brand new thing where you're super charming all the time.
我们可以给你一个全新的东西，让你一直超级迷人。
Being more able to look people in the eye.
能更直视人们的眼睛。
Not always hide behind a microphone.
不总是躲在麦克风后面。
Actually, all joking aside, there is a new hypnosis that works on what's called voluntary baldness syndrome, where they realize that a lot of men are sort of doing it on purpose.
实际上，抛开玩笑，有一种新的催眠作用于所谓的自愿秃头综合症，他们意识到很多男人是故意这样做的。
Why would someone do that on purpose?
为什么有人会故意那样做？
Well, it turns out that hair loss is more of like an act of willful insolence often, and a cry for pity.
事实证明，脱发更多是一种故意的傲慢行为，也是一种博取同情的哭诉。
I used to love my hair.
我过去很喜欢我的头发。
Well, if you loved it so much, why did you get rid of it?
好吧，如果你那么喜欢它，你为什么把它弄掉了？
First of all, I find that offensive. And, Gregor, chime in here because I'm sure you're equally offended.
首先，我觉得那被冒犯了。而且，Gregor，插话进来，因为我肯定你同样被冒犯了。
No, Dimitri used to be bald as an egg, and then he willed it back on.
不，Dimitri过去秃得像个蛋，然后他靠意志力让它又长回来了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I think if you did it at the same time with my mother, we'd get a two for one deal.
我想如果你和我母亲同时做，我们会得到买一送一的优惠。
Package deal.
套餐优惠。
I'm just saying, it's science. If you read The New England Journal of Medicine, this--
我只是说，这是科学。如果你读《新英格兰医学杂志》，这个——
With Gregor and Dmitri aligned and friends again at my expense, I set out in search of the one-eyed hippie hypnotist, Saul Feldstein. But it turns out Saul died in 2019 at the age of 91. So I reach out to other hypnotists, all of whom pretty much hang up on me once I explain the project. So hypnotism is out. The museum is out. I'm stuck with my crap personality, and Etta is stuck with her house full of crap. And Gregor is still at an impasse. But things are about to change.
随着Gregor和Dmitri重新站到一边，并以我的损失为代价恢复了友谊，我开始寻找那位独眼嬉皮催眠师Saul Feldstein。但结果显示Saul已于2019年以91岁高龄去世。所以我联系了其他催眠师，当我解释完项目后，他们基本都挂断了我的电话。所以催眠没戏了。博物馆也没戏了。我被困在我那该死的性格中，而Etta被困在她那装满烂货的房子里。Gregor仍然处于僵局。但事情即将发生变化。
Gregor tells me that Etta has been offered a show at the Carter Burden gallery in Manhattan. Etta is an outsider artist, so the offer of her own exhibition feels like finally, at the age of 88, she's being invited inside. The show, with its formal invitations and coat check, feels like validation.
Gregor告诉我，Etta得到了在曼哈顿Carter Burden画廊举办展览的机会。Etta是一位局外艺术家，所以她自己的展览邀约感觉就像她终于在88岁时被邀请进去了。那场带有正式请柬和衣帽间服务的展览，感觉就像是一种认可。
It's the kind of opportunity Etta has always hoped for. And for Gregor, it feels like an opportunity for her pieces to find good homes outside her home. The show opens on March 21, 2019. Gregor and I make a plan to speak the morning after so he can tell me how it went. When we speak, what Gregor tells me is that things that night took a wild turn.
这是Etta一直希望得到的那种机会。对Gregor来说，这感觉也是她的作品在家里之外找到好归宿的机会。展览于2019年3月21日开幕。Gregor和我计划在第二天早上谈谈，让他告诉我进展如何。当我们交谈时，Gregor告诉我那一晚的情况发生了疯狂的转折。
Do you want to explain?
你想解释一下吗？
Sure. I flew into town for my mom's art opening. OK, we're here at the art opening. It's a pretty good crowd. Everyone's eating wine and cheese.
当然。我飞回城里参加我母亲的艺术展开幕。好的，我们在这儿，艺术展开幕。人群相当不错。大家都在吃着红酒和奶酪。
And it's great, but it's so loud.
很棒，但声音太大了。
It was almost like a cartoon version of my mom's success story in that some stranger guy came up and was like, you're a beautiful woman.
这几乎就像是我母亲成功故事的卡通版，有个陌生人走过来就像说，你是个美丽的女人。
You're beautiful.
你很漂亮。
[LAUGHS] Thank you. That's very nice to hear at my age, I'll tell you that much.
[笑声] 谢谢。我得告诉你，在我这个年纪听到这个真好。
Her ego was buffed from many sides, everything going great.
她的虚荣心得到了多方面的满足，一切进展顺利。
Oh!
噢！
Gregor's dad, Milt, on the other hand, wasn't having as good a time. He spent most of the evening in the corner, nibbling on crackers. At the end of the night, Gregor approached him.
另一方面，Gregor的父亲Milt可没那么好过。他大半个晚上都躲在角落里，啃着饼干。晚上结束时，Gregor走近他。
Well, Father, what did you make of that?
好吧，父亲，你觉得那怎么样？
Oh, it was very nice. It was a little bit exhausting. [CHUCKLES]
噢，很不错。有点累人。[笑声]
He seemed like-- even though he sometimes talks in a quiet voice, he was especially quiet. Like, I could hardly hear him.
他似乎——尽管他有时声音很小，但那天特别安静。就像，我几乎听不见他说话。
I don't know.
我不知道。
On the drive home, Milt conked out. When the family couldn't rouse him, they realized he wasn't just sleeping, but completely unconscious. Etta began yelling, wailing Milt's name. He was driven to the hospital, where the EMTs lifted him onto a gurney. The doctors thought he might be having a stroke, but they couldn't say for sure. In the waiting room, Etta turned to Gregor and said, you might as well order the dumpsters right now, meaning, you win, empty out the house, because if Milt isn't coming back to it, that's it.
在回家的路上，Milt睡着了。当家人无法叫醒他时，他们意识到他不仅是在睡觉，而是完全失去知觉。Etta开始大喊，哀嚎着Milt的名字。他被送往医院，急救人员把他抬上担架。医生以为他可能中风了，但不能确定。在候诊室里，Etta转过身对Gregor说，你现在就把垃圾箱订了吧，意思就是，你赢了，把房子清空，因为如果Milt回不来，就这样了。
How do you know when the Damoclean sword of mortality isn't just dangling above you, but actually falling? How do you know when it's time to pick up the remote, turn off Rachel Maddow, and finally act? The night, a milestone in Etta's career, was meant to symbolize a turning point. And it was, just not the kind she was hoping for. Milt was eventually sent home from the hospital, but his collapse signaled a change for Gregor, too. For so long, he'd been saying, maybe it's time, but maybe it was time to stop saying maybe.
你如何知道死亡的达摩克利斯之剑不仅悬在你头顶，而且真的正在落下？你如何知道什么时候该拿起遥控器，关掉Rachel Maddow，并终于付诸行动？那天晚上，是Etta职业生涯的一个里程碑，本意是象征着一个转折点。它确实是，只是不是她希望的那种。Milt最终从医院回家了，但他的倒下也标志着Gregor的生活发生了改变。这么久以来，他一直在说，也许是时候了，但也许是时候停止说也许了。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, it's Gregor and Jonathan.
嗨，我是Gregor和Jonathan。
Oh, and I thought this was a scam call. How do you like that? How are you?
噢，我还以为这是诈骗电话。你喜欢那样吗？你好吗？
Well, I wouldn't be so sure it's not.
好吧，我不敢肯定那不是。
We haven't finished the call yet.
我们还没谈完话呢。
Right. So what's the pitch? [LAUGHS]
对。那么提议是什么？[笑声]
Johnny wanted to dredge up a bunch of painful family issues.
Johnny想挖出一堆痛苦的家庭问题。
Oh, sure. Why not? The painfuller, the better.
噢，当然。为什么不？越痛苦越好。
I want to talk with Etta about the night of the art opening and the way it affected her thinking about remaining in the house.
我想和Etta谈谈艺术展开幕那晚，以及它如何影响了她对继续住在这栋房子里的看法。
I won't be able to stay here alone. Either I will become ill, or Milt will become ill, and I need somebody to help me. There is a new little piece in my head that says things are going to change.
我不能一个人待在这里。要么我会生病，要么Milt会生病，我需要有人帮助我。我脑子里有一个新的小念头，说事情要发生变化了。
In the aftermath of the art show opening, as Etta's new reality sunk in, another plan began to take shape, one that Etta came up with. Her idea is to pair each of her message-on-a-bottles with the right person. In this way, each one will find the right home.
在艺术展开幕后的余波中，当Etta的新现实逐渐沉淀，另一个计划开始形成，那是Etta自己想出来的。她的想法是将她的“瓶中寄语”与合适的人配对。通过这种方式，每一个都会找到合适的归宿。
I now have a whole shelf full of stuff that I'm now earmarking to give away.
我现在整整架子的东西，我现在正准备送人。
That's something that you've not normally done?
那是你通常没做过的事吗？
No. I'd only gave very few things away to my best friend or to the kids or something like that. Very few. Very, very few.
不。我只送过极少数东西给我最好的朋友或孩子们之类的。极少。非常、非常少。
You think it's at the beginning of something, more of this to come?
你觉得这是某件事的开始，未来会有更多这样的事吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it has to be. It has to be. I take it very seriously when I think of giving a person a bottle. I have to think, would it be good for that person?
是的。是的，必须是。必须是。当我考虑给某人一个瓶子时，我非常认真。我必须想，这对那个人有好处吗？
OK. Now we're rolling. All right.
好吧。现在我们开始了。好了。
A few weeks later, I call Gregor to see how Etta's bottle drive is coming along.
几周后，我给Gregor打电话看Etta的赠瓶活动进展如何。
So she called me this morning, saying, I thought of the perfect person to give the perfect bottle to, but I'm afraid it's going to hurt his feelings.
所以她今天早上给我打电话，说，我想到了给完美的瓶子找完美的人，但我怕会伤害他的感情。
OK.
好的。
She wants to give you a bottle.
她想给你一个瓶子。
She wants to give-- OK, well, that-- wow, that's really nice. Why would that hurt my feelings?
她想给——好的，好吧，那——哇，那真的很棒。为什么会伤害我的感情？
If you give someone a bottle that says, like, I wish I was present, then it's sort of an implication that you're not present. You know what I mean? It could be interpreted sometimes as a sort of a criticism. So I don't know how you'll take it.
如果你给某人一个瓶子上面写着，就像，希望我活在当下，那么这暗含着你并不活在当下。你知道我的意思吗？这有时可以被解释为一种批评。所以我不知道你会怎么看。
Well, did she tell you what my bottle says?
好吧，她告诉你我的瓶子写着什么了吗？
That's as much as I can say at this point. That's as much as I'm authorized to say.
目前我只能说这么多了。这就是我被授权说的全部。
Even though I should know better, know how Gregor will dangle this knowledge over my head like a cat dancer, my curiosity gets the better of me. And so I keep asking Gregor what the bottle says, which he uses as an opportunity to dissect my personality. All I can say, he says, is that it addresses some of your deep-seated issues.
尽管我应该更懂行，知道Gregor会如何像逗猫棒一样把这些知识悬在我的头顶，但好奇心还是战胜了我。所以我一直问Gregor瓶子上写着什么，他利用这个机会剖析我的性格。他说，我只能说，它解决了你的一些深层次问题。
Despite all your insights about other people, you sort of tend to remove yourself from the collective and put yourself in the position of, like, journalistic observer.
尽管你对别人有所有的洞察力，但你倾向于把自己从集体中抽离出来，让自己处于那种，像是，新闻观察者的位置。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
When you have these insights, your dime store insights you bolt on at the end of things where you're like, maybe we all need someone to run to, that Hallmark-y nonsense that you tend to spout at the end of these--
当你有了这些洞察力，你在事情结束时加上去的那些廉价洞察力，就像你说，也许我们都需要有人可以投奔，那种你在这些节目最后倾向于喷出的Hallmark式的废话——
What a jerk. You feel comfortable just saying something like that to someone? Telling me about my dime--
真是个混蛋。你感觉可以随意对某人说这样的话吗？跟我说我的廉价——
No, see, I knew you were going to take it the wrong way.
不，看，我就知道你会想歪。
What's the right way to take that?
想歪的正确方式是什么？
I think, sometimes, you sort of make yourself resistant, like, oh, I don't matter. I'm just the fly on the wall to watching the human condition as people live and die and suffer, and babies are born, and old people are lowered into the ground. Oh, and the dirt hits the coffin. That reminds me of my sponsor. I think you just-- you use this thing to remove yourself from what's actually going on.
我想，有时，你倾向于让自己变得抵抗，就像，噢，我不重要。我只是墙上的苍蝇，看着人类在生死中挣扎，婴儿出生，老人在地下被放下。噢，泥土打在棺材上。这让我想起了我的赞助商。我觉得你只是——你利用这个东西来让自己远离正在发生的事。
OK, all right.
好的，好吧。
You're like, you know what would really make this thing sing?
你就像，你知道什么会让这东西唱歌吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
[CHUCKLES] Now let me just get a shot of you throwing your art off the bridge. That's what we need to finish this.
[轻笑] 现在让我拍一张你把艺术品从桥上扔下去的照片。这就是我们需要完成这个目标的方式。
Over the next couple of years, Etta continues to slowly search out the right homes for her bottles. Whereas in the past, Etta was only able to give away a few, Gregor estimates that she hands out about a hundred. During this time, Milt is in and out of the hospital, with cardiac issues ranging from fainting spells and high blood pressure to an actual heart attack.
在接下来的几年里，Etta继续缓慢地寻找她瓶子的合适归宿。尽管过去Etta只能送出几个，但Gregor估计她送出了大约一百个。在此期间，Milt多次进出医院，心脏问题从昏厥和高血压一直到真正的心脏病发作都有。
But then, in the summer of 2021, it's Etta who received some bad news. Two years after Gregor and I first spoke, Gregor phones to tell me his mother has been diagnosed with brain cancer. The doctor found nine metastases in her brain. They went to three different hospitals in five days, and the consensus was that it wasn't a matter of months, but of weeks. In what felt like only days, Etta went from carrying laundry up the stairs to needing to be carried up the stairs herself.
但随后，在2021年夏天，Etta收到了一些坏消息。Gregor和我第一次谈话两年后，Gregor打电话告诉我他母亲被诊断出患有脑癌。医生在她脑中发现了九处转移灶。他们在五天内去了三家不同的医院，共识是这不是以月计，而是以周计的问题。在感觉只有几天的时间里，Etta从把衣物搬上楼变成需要别人把她搬上楼。
With Etta's illness, Gregor decides to move in-- the whole family does-- into the big, packed house they grew up in. A hospital bed is set up on the main floor in Etta's old office. And Gregor wakes up at sunrise and sits at Etta's bedside in silence. He speaks with her, makes her comfortable. He tells her it's OK to go, that everything is OK.
随着Etta生病，Gregor决定搬进来——全家人都搬进了他们长大的那栋大而拥挤的房子里。一张病床被安置在主楼层Etta的老办公室里。Gregor在日出时醒来，静静地坐在Etta床边。他与她交谈，让她感到舒适。他告诉她走吧没关系，一切都好。
And I stayed there for six weeks, eight weeks, and sort of did the bedside vigil as she slowly died.
我在那里待了六周，八周，并在她缓慢死去时守在床边。
In those final weeks, Gregor saw a change come over Etta.
在最后的几周里，Gregor看到了Etta身上的变化。
In the years running up to her death, she would say things like, listen, there's a rolled-up rug in the attic. That's worth a lot of money. Make sure that they don't cheat you out of that one. That was always kind of a sort of joke, sort of real thing.
在她去世前的几年里，她会说些话，听着，阁楼里有个卷起来的地毯。那个很值钱。确保他们不会在那个上欺骗你。那总是某种笑话，某种真实的事情。
But when the actual room of death and dying was happening, that stuff didn't really come up. It felt more like she was at peace with a lot of stuff. And a lot of the stuff she told me, she would be laying there with her eyes shut, but smiling. And I'm like, Mom, what are you thinking about? And she would just-- just with her hand, she would indicate that she's dancing by just flowing her hand in the air. It felt like a great death.
但当真正的死亡和临终房间发生时，那些东西并没有真的出现。感觉她更像是对很多东西感到平静。她告诉我的很多事，她会闭着眼睛躺在那儿，但微笑着。我问，妈，你在想什么？她只会——用手，她会通过在空中流动来表示她在跳舞。感觉就像一场伟大的死亡。
The words on the bottles had finally sunk in. In the end, Etta could dance out of the world gracefully, no grasping. It's the living who are left to grasp.
瓶子上的字终于印入心底。最后，Etta可以优雅地跳舞离开世界，没有执念。留下活人去执着。
Since my mom died, it feels like it's harder to throw things out than I thought.
自从我妈去世后，感觉扔东西比我想象中要难。
This is Gregor's sister, Lexi, again. Like Etta, Lexi is an artist. And like Gregor, she's surprised by how, after all the years trying to get her mom to let go of her stuff, she herself is finding it so hard to let go of that very same stuff.
这是Gregor的姐姐Lexi，又是她。像Etta一样，Lexi也是艺术家。像Gregor一样，她惊讶于多年来试图让母亲放下她的东西后，她自己发现放下同样的东西是多么困难。
It just feels really hard to-- her art, it's like a part of her.
真的感觉很难——她的艺术，就像她的一部分。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's not her.
但那不是她。
Yeah.
是的。
I had an interesting conversation with my dad the other day, who was, of course, really grief-stricken. And he was saying, why do people make art? And he thinks the reason people make art is so that they're not forgotten when they die. Like, you do something that remains in the world.
我和我父亲前几天有次有趣的谈话，他当然非常悲痛。他在说，人们为什么要创作艺术？他认为人们创作艺术的原因是为了让他们死后不被遗忘。就像，你做了一些留在世上的事。
I think of her a lot.
我经常想到她。
Do you still carry with you your mother's love? Do you feel it?
你还带着你母亲的爱吗？你感觉到了吗？
I carry her with me, I mean, in the way that when I experience something, I can't help but hear my mother's voice making fun of me for my description of what I'm experiencing. I might be describing something, telling her about just some quotidian thing in the day. You know, this is a nice sunset, but it'd be nicer if that truck weren't backing up. And I can hear her being like, why are you so rotten, you know? What is wrong with you? I mean, that type of thing.
我带着她，我的意思是，当我经历某事时，我不禁听到我母亲的声音在取笑我对所经历之事的描述。我可能会描述某事，告诉她一天中随便什么事。你知道，这是一个美好的日落，但如果那辆卡车不在倒车会更好。我能听到她在那儿说，你怎么那么刻薄，你知道吗？你怎么了？我的意思是，那种事。
You can try to move your aging parents out of their house. You can treat death like a to-do list with items to check off. But ultimately, you can't control how people live or die. Even after Etta's death, Milt remained in that very same house. It's Dimitri and his own family that move in so that Milt doesn't have to be alone. And over the next few years, Gregor, in fits and starts and with disregard for what anyone thinks, continues to work on the museum. Only, it's become less about a full-fledged museum open to the public and more of just a place to honor his mom.
你可以尝试把你年迈的父母搬离他们的房子。你可以把死亡当作一张待办事项清单来勾选。但最终，你无法控制人们如何生或死。即使在Etta去世后，Milt仍然住在同一栋房子里。是Dimitri和他自己的家人搬了进来，这样Milt就不必孤单了。在接下来的几年里，Gregor断断续续地、不顾他人的想法，继续致力于博物馆。只是，它已经不再是一个向公众开放的全功能博物馆，而更多是纪念他母亲的地方。
And then one day, Gregor texts saying he found a sealed box in the Victorian with my name on it, written in Etta's hand. When the box arrives, I unravel what seems like yards and yards of bubble wrap. Etta had taken great care. The bottle is a beautiful blue, the blue of a childhood toy. It's curvaceous and feels good in my hand. Upon it, Etta laid out her words to me.
然后有一天，Gregor发短信说他在维多利亚式住宅里发现了一个密封的盒子，上面写着我的名字，用Etta的手迹写的。当盒子送到时，我解开了似乎有几码长的气泡膜。Etta非常小心。瓶子是美丽的蓝色，童年玩具的蓝色。它曲线优美，握在手里感觉很好。在上面，Etta写下了她给我的话。
I would love to live like a river flows, carried by the surprise of its own unfolding. See what I mean?
我渴望像河流一样生活，被其自身展开的惊喜所携带。明白我的意思吗？
I do. But how dare she? I'm kidding. Cue the outro music. Cue the dime store insight. Whether it's to a museum in the wilds of upstate New York or to a landfill, none of us knows where we're flowing. In the face of that, we need to learn how to let go.
我明白。但她怎么敢？我在开玩笑。放片尾曲。放那个廉价洞察力。无论是去纽约州北部荒野的博物馆，还是去垃圾填埋场，我们都不知道自己流向何方。面对这一点，我们需要学会如何放下。
My feeling about what comes after death is constantly changing. I don't have a spiritual practice, so all I have is a feeling. And my feeling today is that bodies are vessels, just like colorful bottles are vessels, just like podcasts and houses packed with stuff, and all of art is. It's all just stuff. And stuff can be beautiful, but it's there to help us get closer to the non-stuff. Because, like the words Etta inscribed on one of her final bottles, all important matters are invisible.
我对死后会发生什么的看法在不断改变。我没有精神修行，所以我有的只是一种感觉。我今天的感觉是，身体是容器，就像彩色的瓶子是容器，就像播客和装满东西的房子，以及所有的艺术一样。一切都只是东西。东西可以很美，但它们在那里是为了帮助我们更接近非东西。因为，就像Etta在她最后的瓶子之一上铭刻的话，所有重要的事情都是隐形的。
Jonathan Goldstein. That story is part of the new season of his show, Heavyweight. It was produced by Phoebe Flanagan with help from Kalila Holt and Stevie Lane. If you do not know Heavyweight, you can find it wherever you get your podcasts. I have to say, one great episode to start with is Jonathan's original season 1 episode that's called Gregor, about his friend Gregor, who you just heard, who, in that episode, is on a mission to get justice from the pop star Moby.
Jonathan Goldstein。那个故事是他节目《重磅》（Heavyweight）新一季的一部分。它由Phoebe Flanagan制作，Kalila Holt和Stevie Lane提供帮助。如果你不知道《重磅》，你可以在任何获得播客的地方找到它。我必须说，一个开始的好剧集是Jonathan的第一季原版剧集，叫《Gregor》，是关于他的朋友Gregor，就是你刚听到的那个，他在那一集中正执行一项从流行歌星Moby那里寻求正义的任务。
Well, our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who helped put the show together today include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mando, Stowe Nelson, Robin Reid, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, and Marisa Robertson-Textor. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Aviva DeKornfeld制作。今天帮助把节目放在一起的人包括Phia Bennin、Michael Comite、Suzanne Gaber、Cassie Howley、Seth Lind、Tobin Low、Katherine Rae Mando、Stowe Nelson、Robin Reid、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Alissa Shipp、Christopher Swetala和Marisa Robertson-Textor。我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Emma Munger. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. A reminder that if you like our show and listen to it a lot, please consider signing up as a This American Life Partner. Do it for the stuff you get, or do it simply because you want to help us keep making the show the way we do it now. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
今天特别感谢Emma Munger。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流电台分发给公共广播电台。提醒一下，如果你喜欢我们的节目并经常收听，请考虑注册成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴。为了你得到的东西去做，或者仅仅因为你想帮助我们继续按现在的方式制作节目。在thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners加入。
Thanks this week to Life Partners Fabian Frey, Cathy D, Anastasia Ragland, and Nancy Berault.
感谢本周的合作伙伴Fabian Frey、Cathy D、Anastasia Ragland和Nancy Berault。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. After just one week, making maybe 1,500 homemade AI videos, he's quitting Sora.
一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。仅仅一周后，制作了大概1500个自制AI视频，他要退出Sora了。
It was a scourge on my life. It was a shadow that was always with me.
它是生活中的一场灾难。它是我身边的一道阴影。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。